Yesterday, I brought you very interesting clips
from an interview that Dr. Anthony Foushee gave
to 60 Minutes on Sunday night. Now, Donald Trump
didn't like that interview and has now called Dr.
Foushee a disaster, seems to group him in with
idiots on Corona virus and openly mold the idea
of firing Dr. Foushee during a call yesterday.
Now, remember that Dr. Foushee said during his 60
Minutes interview that he's now getting threats,
needs full time security. The direction of the
pandemic is unclear. He's not surprised Trump got
coronavirus. Trump is furious. This was all from a
campaign call that took place yesterday, Monday.
There were reporters on the call. No one is
disputing what Trump said. Here are the reports.
Jeff Mason from Reuters tweeted that Trump is
disparaging Dr. Foushee on the call. Says People
are tired of hearing from Foushee and all these
idiots and says that Foushee has, quote, been
here for 500 years. Trump also mused about firing
Foushee. If it weren't for the negative press, he
would anticipate if he were to do it. And again,
said Foushee is a disaster will stake in from
ABC tweeted about this same call that Trump said,
quote, People are tired of Kofod. People
are saying whatever. Trump is now discussing
firing Dr. Foushee on a campaign all staff call
saying it's a bigger bomb. If you fire him,
Caitlin Collins from CNN. Tweeting, quote, On call
with campaign staff, President Trump says people
are tired of hearing about coronavirus. People are
just saying whatever. Just leave us alone. They're
tired of it. People are tired of hearing Foushee
and all these idiots. Foushee is a nice guy. He's
been here for 500 years. And then subsequently,
as reported by Caitlyn Collins, Trump said, quote,
Foushee is a disaster. If I listened to him,
we'd have five hundred thousand deaths, which,
by the way, we might eventually, before it's
all said and done before later saying it would
be 700000 or 800000. If there's a reporter
on, you can have it. Just the way I said it,
I couldn't care less. Caitlyn Colins adding
that CNN was given access to this call
by a source. So every reporter who was listening
to the call on the same page about what was said.
I think that Donald Trump really is thinking of
firing Dr. Foushee. He may be kind of floating it
to see what the responses from campaign staff.
I think the response if Trump fires Foushee.
I do think it would be the nail in the coffin
of Trump's campaign. I know we're looking at key
states and comparing 20-20 polling to 2016. And it
could go this way. It could go that way. I think
at this point, if Trump fires Foushee at this late
stage, it's game over for for for Donald Trump,
fortunately. Well, let me put a different way.
Hopefully, Dr. Foushee will soon be working
for a different president. His role in fighting
Corona virus will be rehabilitated. But I don't
know how much longer Foushee is going to be
working for Trump at this rate. I think if
Trump gets reelected, there's a very good chance
Foushee Foushee gets fired. And it's interesting
because when Trump says people are tired of the
pandemic, we are tired of the administration
continuing to mess up the pandemic. That's what
I'm tired of. I'm tired that there was never a
coherent response, that there is this constant
blundering of the reaction to the virus. That's
what I'm tired of. And if Trump and his useless
administration would have listened to Foushee
from the get go, the economic damage would have
been mitigated and things would be far better than
they are now. We would have fewer cases. We would
have fewer deaths. I am sick of coronavirus. Trump
is right, but I'm even more sick of Donald Trump
and his followers and their mishandling. I'm tired
of staying home so they don't contracter spread
the virus. But I'm more tired of Trump's cult
not doing what they should've done to get
this under control. But for the president
to be tired of it too, won't help it go
away. And that's why he has to be removed.